sperrstunde gestrichen beherbergungs
verbote abgeschafft warum mehrere
gerichte dekor ohne regeln wieder kippen
kitas im chor ohne herbst wie kinder und
betreuerinnen mit den einschränkungen
klarkommen und der schnee ist da die
fans bleiben weg sollten zeigt sich
bereit für den start in die
weltcup-saison unter besonderen
bedingungen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am freitag
norbert lehmann ist auch dabei für den
sport 1 schimmelbauer familie
was tun wenn sich corona weiter so
rapide ausbreitet wie derzeit die
sperrstunde in der kneipe vorverlegen
weniger gäste bei privaten feiern
erlauben und innerdeutsche reisen aus
hotspots erschweren so soll die
bevölkerung geschützt werden doch nun
macht die justiz den regierenden einen
strich durch die rechnung und kippt
einen beschluss nach dem anderen ganz
aktuell die sperrstunde in berlin
anselm stern für eric fanbus ist heute
ein tag der freude der berliner bar
betreiber hatte zusammen mit zehn
anderen geklagt gegen die anti virus
sperrstunde und gewonnen darf stand
jetzt hier gäste empfangen und das auch
nach 23 uhr also grundsätzlich sind wir
erstmal sehr glücklich über die
entscheidung
generell jetzt hat die sperrstunde
aufgehoben und nicht dass alkohol aus
der alkoholausschank bei uns ist der
alkoholausschank gar nicht auch
unbedingt im vordergrund sondern
tatsächlich einfach auch das
beisammensein wie gesagt ein tag der
freude für die einen für die anderen zb
die regierung der hauptstadt ist es ihr
das genaue gegenteil der berliner senat
wird juristisch gegen das urteil des
verwaltungsgerichts berlin vorgehen
wir wissen alle dass die lage ernst ist
und was jetzt elf bars dürfen lange
öffnen die anderen nicht kein zustand
der klarheit schafft fest steht das
berliner verwaltungsgericht hat die
sperrstunde klar beurteilt nicht
verhältnismäßig weil nicht erforderlich
ein fall für die gerichte ist immer
öfter auch das beherbergungs verbot
gedacht war es als bundesweite regel
mittlerweile wird es in immer mehr
bundesländern von der justiz gekippt
oder von den landesregierungen wieder
abgeschafft zuletzt heute in bayern das
beherbergungs verbot aufzuheben ist
machbar
auch wenn die zahlen erhöht sind denn
die beherbergung an sich ist ja nicht
das risiko sondern das was sich
mache dort wo ich beherbergt werde gehe
ich auf eine feier gehe ich irgendwo in
enge räume in eine bar da kommt das
risiko her
corona risiko und corona regelstreit
jetzt nicht mehr nur in der politik
sondern auch vor den gerichten der
republik ja aber mir ist felix
zimmermann aus unserer redaktion recht
und justiz hallo felix kulow
die persönliche freiheit einschränken
das macht die politik ja um dem corona
virus etwas entgegenzusetzen
warum werden jetzt diese maßnahmen
reihenweise wieder gekippt die gerichte
kippen die maßnahmen wenn sie sagen die
sind doch für den infektionsschutz gar
nicht erfordert die bringen doch gar
nichts beispiel sperrstunde
er sagt das verwaltungsgericht berlin
soeben übrigens bestätigte das
oberverwaltungsgericht
berlin-brandenburg wenn personen nach 23
uhr im restaurant weiter sitzen ohne
alkoholkonsum wo soll denn da das
besondere infektionsrisiko liegen
dieses liege doch gerade bei privaten
feiern mit alkohol und in der tat wenn
die sperrstunde droht und das ganze dann
nach hause verlagert wird ist natürlich
das infektionsrisiko mit alkohol
beispiel beherbergungs verbote
einige gerichte sagen personen reisende
aus corona hotspots die sind eine
gesundheitsgefahr für andere wieder
anlegergerechte seien dann aber naja im
bloßen reisen und blusen beherbergen
liegt doch gar kein infektionsrisiko
kein gesteigertes infektionsrisiko aber
dann sind der politik quasi die hände
gebunden dann kann sie ja gar nicht mehr
schnell auf das infektionsgeschehen
reagieren oder in der tat im rechtsstaat
sind der politik die hände gebunden
sie muss eben innerhalb der verfassung
agieren und einige gerichte haben bei
manchen maßnahmen zweifeln indes ist es
aber auch so wenn die politik plausible
nachvollziehbare regeln macht dann sagen
die gerichte natürlich die politik hat
auch einen spielraum
entscheidungsspielraum die zeiten
allerdings wo die gerichte zu beginn der
pandemie die maßnahmen zu durch gewogen
haben sind vorbei denn man muss jemand
beachten die gesundheitsschutz ist kein
super grundrecht was alle anderen
grundrechte schlägt sondern der staat
muss die anderen grundrechte
versammlungsfreiheit demonstrations-
gebot dafür sammlung
zwar hat die freizügigkeit immer im
blick haben und darf nicht diese anderen
grundrechte zu sehr einschränken
zugunsten des gesundheitsschutzes
vielen dank felix zimmermann das hilft
uns ein bisschen die zusammenhänge zu
verstehen
danke schauen wir nach nordrhein
westfalen wo sich aktuell mehr menschen
anstecken als in jedem anderen
bundesland das rk ii meldet heute 2154
neue infektionen innerhalb eines tages
mittlerweile lebt jeder dritte in nrw in
einem risikogebiet ab köln rheinabwärts
und fast im gesamten ruhrgebiet liegen
die zahlen über 50 neuinfektionen pro
100000 einwohnern in sieben tagen wie
das land diese zahl wieder senken will
berichtet thomas münten was gepflegt wie
die risiko in den städten sperrstunde 23
uhr und kontakt beschränkungen für
feiern auf nur noch fünf personen
armin laschet galt lange als gemäßigt im
umgang mit der pandemie
das ist vorbei wir bitten da alle um
verständnis dass in dieser ernsten lage
wenn wir schulen offen halten wollen
kitas offen halten wollen das
wirtschaftliche leben offen halten
wollen alles was den freizeitbereich
betrifft eingeschränkt werden muss heute
mittag informierte lasse die kommunen
sie müssen sich um die kontrolle kümmern
bekommen aber auch die meiste kritik zu
spüren das problem allein mit
städtischen mitarbeitern lässt sich
düsseldorfer altstadt zb kaum
kontrollieren
der wurde darüber gesprochen dass wir
bei bedarf eben unter umständen etwa
auch auf die bundespolizei zurückgreifen
können und die bürger die zustimmung
überwiegt aber der zweifel am konzept
wächst ich sage mal für die wenigen die
dann wirklich nachts betrunken sind und
dann den sicherheitsstand verletzten
dafür dann so eine so eine regelung zu
schaffen weiß ich nicht ich folge der
massen fließt und habe mir mal dass ein
gutes im winter kommen hier kann mir
keiner beweisen dass weniger koma fälle
passieren wenn die um 10 zu machen ohne
oder mainz private feiern zu hause
sollen aber nicht kontrolliert werden
wir machen keine gesetze wo polizei am
ende verpflichtet ist in private räume
zu gehen
hier gilt der besondere schutz der
wohnung das haben im kanzleramt deutlich
gemacht gemeinsam die länder hessen
rheinland pfalz und nordrhein westfalen
die landesregierung hofft dass sie bis
weihnachten wieder lockerungen
beschließen kann einen blick auf den
neuinfektionen in deutschland sie haben
einen neuen höchststand erreicht sind
allerdings nur bedingt mit den zahlen
vom frühjahr zu vergleichen unter
anderem weil mehr getestet wird
die zahl der gemeldeten neuinfektionen
stieg um 7334 deutlich hoch ging auch
die zahl der belegten intensivbetten
durch corona patienten von 510 letzte
woche auf jetzt 6 190 fast 8700
intensivbetten sind noch frei da fragen
sich natürlich viele eltern ob bald
wieder schulen und kitas geschlossen
werden so wie im frühjahr
dafür gebe es keinen grund sagt
familienministerin giffey das robert
koch institut untersucht zurzeit auch
die korona situation in kitas und kommt
zum zwischenergebnis kindertagesstätten
sind keine infektionsherde und der
regelbetrieb laufe gut
verena garrett hat eine kita im saarland
besucht
morgenkreis in der kita charlottenburg
für die drei- bis sechsjährigen im
september erst gab es hier ein corona
fall im krippen teil der einrichtung für
die großen konnte der alltag trotzdem
weitergehen wie gewohnt denn krippe und
kindergarten sind seit monaten streng
getrennt normalerweise spielen die
kinder alle gemeinsam mit ein bisschen
würden uns kämpfen wieder entfall der
müssten allerdings die ganze kita
geschlossen werden
und das was suchen wir zu vermeiden
massiver personalmangel war schon vor
corona ein thema die pandemie kratzt
weiter am bestand zeitweise sind
erzieherinnen mit erhöhtem
krankheitsrisiko zu hause geblieben die
folge öffnungszeiten konnten hier
mehrere wochen nicht eingehalten werden
wir versuchen dann innerhalb von von der
einrichtung zu gucken wie bei uns
dagegen da die stützen der machen
kollegin mehr überstunden die
erzieherinnen konnten frei entscheiden
ob sie in der einrichtung eine maske
tragen wollen oder nicht und überhaupt
kontakt und nähe unbedingt notwendig
wenn es die entwicklung der
infektionszahlen zulässt die das sind
keine infektionsherde
kinder sind keine infektions treiber und
wir wollen alles dafür tun dass die
aufrechterhaltung des regelbetriebs so
lange es geht
ermöglicht wird allerdings muss man eben
gucken wenn ihr infektionszahlen jetzt
weiter steigen
ob man beispielsweise dann im mund
nasenschutz zumindestens für die
betreuerinnen eben dann vorgibt
normalität für die kinder so viel es
geht
das soll im corona herbst in den
kindertagesstätten möglich sein
ständig neue chor ohne meldungen mit
neuen maßnahmen und einschränkungen
einen überblick zu den aktuellen
entwicklungen zum krone virus in
deutschland und weltweit finden sie
jederzeit im live-blog in unserer zdf
heute app ein corona hotspot in europa
ist und bleibt weiterhin unser nachbar
frankreich dort melden die behörden
30621 neue fälle das sind mehr als je
zuvor an einem tag deshalb gilt ab
morgen in paris und acht weiteren
großstädten die neue nächtliche
ausgangssperre
auch in rumänien wächst der druck nach
tagen mit infektionen auf rekordniveau
drohen engpässe auf den
intensivstationen und gerade im moment
berät belgien über neue maßnahmen eine
mögliche davon restaurants und cafés
könnten für vier wochen komplett
geschlossen werden
auch über den brüsseler eu gipfel liegt
wie ein schatten die korona pandemie
doch ein thema drängte auch am tag zwei
nach vorn der exit die zeit wird knapp
und london macht druck premierminister
boris johnson sagt weitere gespräche
seien sinnlos sollte brüssel seine
position nicht grundsätzlich ändern
die eu allerdings reagiert gelassen
bei den tarifverhandlungen für den
öffentlichen dienst sind die positionen
noch weit auseinander
die arbeitgeber haben heute ihr angebot
vorgelegt für die rund 2,5 millionen
beschäftigten von bund und kommunen
insgesamt 3,5 prozent mehr in den
nächsten drei jahren die gewerkschaften
nennen das angebot geradezu respektlos
sie fordern 4,8 prozent für ein jahr
corona bringt viele branchen ins trudeln
auch die landwirtschaft und da vor allem
die schweinehalter sie seien in der
größten krise seit jahrzehnten sagt der
bauernverband in vielen schlachthöfen
wird weniger geschlachtet teilweise
wegen corona teilweise weil sich die
afrikanische schweinepest ausbreitet
die preise sind deswegen im freien fall
und so werden die bauern ihre schweine
nicht mehr los und viele tiere leiden in
überfüllten stellen
daniela sonntag es wird immer enger in
manchen stellen bei der
agrargenossenschaft im thüringischen
reinstedt schweine stau nennt das der
vorstandsvorsitzende udo große für
mehrere hundert tiere bekommt er keinen
termin beim schlachthof weil dort wegen
corona die kapazitäten geschrumpft sind
die werden jetzt mehr gefüttert und und
wachsen natürlich auch weiter so
irgendwann werden die buchten zu klein
und dann gibt es richtige probleme
eigentlich hätte ringt in der situation
die schweine loszuwerden
erst corona jetzt noch die afrikanische
schweinepest züchter und nester unter
druck der preis fürs kino schweine
schlachtfleisch in diesem jahr stetig
gesunken ein eur 27 derzeit der heute in
erfurt wieder gewählte vorsitzende des
bauernverbandes kritisiert die
politischen rahmenbedingungen
wir haben ständig neue verordnungen
verschärfungen wir sind importen
ausgesetzt von lebensmitteln die nicht
unseren standards entsprechen
wir haben eine gesellschaftspolitische
diskussion um den richtigen weg der
landwirtschaft das belastet uns die
diskussion über intensive tierhaltung
viele bauern hätten aber auch jahrelang
von diesem system profitiert sagt
claudia gerster von der
arbeitsgemeinschaft bäuerliche
landwirtschaft fördergelder umverteilen
wünscht sich der ökoverband da stehen
wir für eine kleine für eine regionale
bäuerliche landwirtschaft wie wir jetzt
sehr auch in der korona größe gesehen
haben dass es wichtig ist das für eine
regionale produktion haben die menschen
vor ort im prinzip ernähren kann und am
ende müssten auch die verbraucher für
vernünftige qualität tiefer in die
tasche greifen
in oberbayern hat es auf einer baustelle
einen schweren unfall gegeben
vier menschen kamen dabei ums leben die
männer hatten auf einem gerüst unter
einer betondecke gearbeitet als diese
einstürzte sie wurden von den trümmern
begraben
eine weitere person wurde leicht
verletzt mir ist zu dem unglück kommen
konnte ist noch unklar
den hunger in der welt stoppen das
hatten sich die vereinten nationen
eigentlich bis 2030 vorgenommen doch die
botschaft zum heutigen welternährungstag
ist ernüchternd momentan wird die lage
eher schlimmer im vergangenen jahr gab
es rund 690 millionen chronisch
unterernährt wegen der korona pandemie
könnten es bis ende des jahres noch
einmal 130 millionen mehr werden
am meisten betroffen ist afrika südlich
der sahara
aber dort gibt es auch projekte die
hoffnung machen
tim kröger berichtet aus kenia es sind
seltsam anmutende gebilde die im garten
der hilfsorganisation save spaces von
penninger muslime stehen die ernte aber
ist gut weil sie hier auf
hydrochlorothiazid das bedeutet mehr
ertrag auf kleinem raum und weniger
wasser verbraucht das wir sammeln
konnten um den anbau zu beginnen reicht
nicht um ein größeres stück land zu
kaufen also haben wir uns für die
hydrokultur entschieden weil sie weniger
platz brauchen
der garten soll regelmäßige einkünfte
für die hilfsorganisation garantieren
sie unabhängiger von spenden machen
bei der hydrokultur wachsen die pflanzen
nicht im erdreich sondern in behältern
etwa mit granulat
peter tigges gehört zu jenen die glauben
dass die hydrokultur afrikas
ernährungsprobleme lösen kann
das ist keine neue erfindung er aber
habe sie einfacher gemacht für den
einsatz in afrika sagt er experimentiert
mit neuen effektiven methoden in afrika
die herausforderung in afrika ist der
wasserverbrauch und der platz land wird
immer teurer die menschen ziehen in
urbanen gebieten wie bei move into aber
nie wie es überall wo es nur wenig platz
aber viele menschen gibt wie etwa auch
in flüchtlingslagern können solche
techniken für gute erträge sorgen und
1900 uns um et tennisturnier in köln ja
und da hat sich alexander zverev ins
halbfinale gekämpft der
weltranglistensiebte zeitweise mit
problemen gegen den weithin unbekannten
südafrikanischen qualifikanten leute
harris am ende aber sieht es wäre
verdient mit 6 4 3 6 6 0
zverev beginnt so konzentriert wie
gestern gegen verdasco
ein frühes break verschafft ihm vorteile
gegen lloyd harris die in 95 der
weltrangliste schöne passiert schläge
wie dieser bringen den sechs zu vier
satzgewinne im zweiten satz wäre
plötzlich mit seinem spiel her ist dem
team zweimal den aufschlag ab und
gewinnt den satz mit 6 zu 3 2 geführt im
dritten satz als eine verletzung beim
südafrikaner aufbricht nach kurzer
behandlungspause kann harris zwar
weiterspielen aber nicht mehr so
dynamisch wie zuvor
zwar holt sich den dritten satz ohne
mühe mit 6 0 und steht im halbfinale von
köln dfb-pokal gestern abend düren gegen
bayern der fünftligist schlug sich
durchaus beachtliche münchen die klaren
favoriten siegten mit einer b-mannschaft
13 0
bayern neuzugang eric maxim choupo
moting traf gleich zweimal in der 24 und
75 minute dennoch die amateure aus düren
am ende mit erhobenen haupt morgen start
des alpinen ski-weltcups traditionell im
österreichischen sölden und traditionell
machen die frauen im riesenslalom den
anfang am sonntag sind die männer dran
zuschauer sind wegen der korona pandemie
dieses jahr nicht zugelassen
heute morgen in sölden neuschnee und
dunkle wolken passend zu den vorzeichen
der deutschen frauen nach dem rücktritt
von viktoria rebensburg und erwartungen
natürlich andere wie es in den letzten
jahren waren und die hoffe dass die eine
oder andere über dings hinauswächst und
wirklich dass leistungen die sie im
training gezeigt haben am samstag dann
umsetzen kann
lena dürr rückt jetzt in den fokus im
slalom eine bank im riesenslalom war der
aktien der platz vom vorjahr in solln
ihr bestes saison-ergebnis auf das
frauen team des dsv wartet also eine
schwere saison
wir sind zwar der damen zweiter lauf
morgen bei uns live im zdf ab 12 das
wochenendwetter wird für die meisten
herbstlich trüb aber nächste woche
ändert sich was einzelheiten dazu gleich
von katja honnefer so viel von uns für
den moment schön dass sie dabei waren
das heute journal heute mit claus kleber
um 22 uhr und an dieser stelle hier
übernimmt morgen barbara hahlweg einen
gemütlichen abend noch und ein schönes
wochenende für sie
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren mit
nordostwind strömen die wolken hier aus
richtung polen über uns hinweg weiter in
richtung frankreich heute gab es mal
chancen für die sonne zumindest mal im
nordwesten deutschlands
da ist der himmel auch in der nacht
häufig klar und ab und zu bildet sich
etwas nebel
es fällt doch noch etwas regen hier in
der osthälfte und die temperaturen
sinken auf werte zwischen 10 grad auf
rügen und 3 grad am niederrhein und am
alpenrand
morgen steigen die werte auf 5 grad an
den alpen und bis auf 13 grad an der
ostsee und das wird wieder ein recht
trüber tag und es fällt auch noch ein
wenig regen hier zum beispiel in sachsen
auch in niederbayern und in oberbayern
die sonne sehen sie auch mal vielleicht
westlich des rheins und an den küsten
von nord- und ostsee sowie im emsland am
sonntag geht es wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen mehr sonne bei temperaturen von
acht bis 13 grad und dann wird es in der
nächsten woche von tag zu tag ein
bisschen bilder am mittwoch erwarten uns
temperaturen von 14 bis 18 grad
schönen abend noch